jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir monsieur le
premier ministre
on se retrouve à dix neuf jours du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nicolas sarkozy est en
tête du premier tour selon lê huu des
sondages mais sans réserve de voir
apparemment pour le second face à
françois hollande mais le président
candidat vous allez nous le confirme et
veut croire qu'une autre campagne
démarrera au soir du premier tour vous
nous direz donc si c'est votre avis et
pour vous interroger dans un instant
fredrik du moulin de l' agence france
presse sera là et puis perrine tarneaud
de public sénat d'abord jean pierre
raffarin vous estimiez au tout à fait
récemment il ya quelques semaines que
nicolas sarkozy avait un peu plus d'une
chance sur trois d'être réélu quel est
votre pronostic aujourd'hui on soir
michel grossiord écoutez je pense qu'on
est à une chance sur deux aujourd'hui je
pense que ce sera très serré et comme
tout scrutin serré les choses sont assez
aléatoires
c'est une performance exceptionnelle de
six semaines de campagne que nicolas
sarkozy a rétabli en fait une situation
dans laquelle il est est au début de
l'année plutôt en difficulté
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
perspective où tout le monde reconnaît
que la probabilité qu'ils sont très
serrés est assez forte et qui dit très
serey die aléatoire parce que personne
ne peut dire si on a 50 + epsilon 50
plus quelque chose de quel côté le
hasard ou les circonstances fontanes et
bien en tous les cas il se présente
comme le candidat antisystème voudrais
pas c'est un peu gonflé après cinq ans
passés à l'elysée mais c'est un peu
l'astuce un personnel de nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir ce sentiment d'être très très
libre en campagne et d'être quelqu'un
qui a trouvé lui même à l'intérieur de
lui-même des libertés nouvelles pour
sortir d'être de ce personnage qui était
un personnage prépare la fonction
présidentielle par la crise est au fond
il a trouvé des libertés nouvelles il a
trouvé des attitudes il a trouvé un
temps qu est un ton au fond assez
différent du président avec un candidat
beaucoup plus libres alors c'est vrai
que le paradoxe c'est que finalement
c'est le candidat sortant qui celui qui
propos
c'est à dire qu'il est le candidat du
changement et finalement que monsieur
hollande
par cette campagne qui n'en est pas une
fini par être comme le conservateur de
cette campagne est au fond c'était d'un
côté il ya le mouvement de l'autre côté
il ya un peu l'immobilisme et c'est le
sortant qui est porteur de changements
ce qui est en effet une certaine
performant on y reviendra parce que
quand même françois hollande à ces
propositions elles sont nombreuses on
attend le détail de celles de nicolas
sarkozy quand jean pierre raffarin
oui mais enfin nicolas sarkozy a déjà
annoncé un certain nombre d'idées fortes
qui ont fait débat et les propositions
de monsieur hollande fois c'est peu
débat et on a plutôt le sentiment que
monsieur hollande a fait le pari d'un
référendum pour ou contre sarkozy et que
là il s'est trompé
je pense que il y à un diagnostic de
monsieur hollande sur la situation du
pays qui était un mauvais diagnostic est
d'ailleurs le meilleur révélateur de la
faiblesse de monsieur hollande c'est la
montée de monsieur mélenchon qu'est ce
que signifie cette poussée de monsieur
mélenchon si ce n'est un doute sur la
campagne monsieur hollande
il est clair que tout comme monsieur
chevènement avait créé un doute sur la
campagne jospin monsieur mélenchon
montre qu'au fond les français de gauche
aujourd'hui doute un peu des
orientations cette montée mentionnant qu
à l'ump vous l'encouragez un jean luc
mélenchon on n'a pas besoin de ça il est
assez créatifs lui-même donc mais il est
évident que il n'y aurait pas de progrès
mélenchon si la campagne hollande ont
été d'une grande crédibilité mais au
moins ça n'est pas une erreur fatale que
vous commettez jean-pierre a faim parce
que vous vous aimez tellement mélenchon
qu'il monte c'est vrai mais tous ces
chiffres se reportent sur françois
hollande au second tour
oui mais l'analyse que fait nicolas
sarkozy
on verra si les bonnes raisons c'est
qu'une campagne électorale c'est une
question de dynamique et donc nicolas
sarkozy compte sur un premier tour dans
lequel il aura la dynamique et donc il
est clair que monsieur mélenchon est un
parasite de la dynamique hollande pour
monsieur hollande monsieur mélenchon
freine la dynamique donc il est
important aujourd'hui dans la stratégie
nicolas sarkozy d'arriver en tête du
premier tour et avoir une dynamique de
campagne
donc aujourd'hui
françois hollande est quoi une divine
surprise pour nicolas sahnoun on parce
que c'est pas jusque-là non ceux des
disons que la dynamique aujourd'hui à
gauche et celle de mélenchon
la dynamique à droite et celle de
nicolas sarkozy et de ce point de vue là
monsieur hollande d'un sentiment d'être
un peu encalminé très bien alors vous
avez dit que nicolas sarkozy dans ses
habits de candidat à sa réélection avait
retrouvé toute sa liberté
y'a pas des choses qui vous gêne quand
même quand il dénonce les corses
intermediary quand il tape à mort sur
les syndicats encore hier ya quelques
heures sur la cgt qui ouvertement prend
position contre lui également contre la
cfdt qui a bien pris soin de ne pas
prendre position
alors bien sûr qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses avec lesquelles je ne
suis pas à 100% d'accord ça a été le cas
de beaucoup de chose est sûre les corps
intermédiaires j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de lui dire et d'ailleurs
depuis il change il a changé son
discours puisqu'il parle de certains
corinthiens médiator donc je pense qu
avec l françois chérèque il est entendu
dans la bouche de nicolas sarkozy des
propos dangereux se ravise je pense que
il est clair que certaines organisations
syndicales ont eu tort de politiser à
l'excès leur combat et que ce qui leur
arrive
elles l'ont bien cherché c'est aller
attaquer nicolas sarkozy quand il était
président il ne pouvait pas répondre
mais le nicolas sarkozy candidat y
répond à tout le monde et quand on vient
manifester dans ce contre sa permanence
quand on vient sur son lieu de candidat
et il faudrait que nicolas sarkozy fasse
comme si on ne savait pas les liens qui
existent entre la cgt le parti
communiste et le front de gauche c'est
une vérité est à mon avis la cgt était
bien maladroite de sept mètres dans
cette mauvaise position
il lui arrive ce qu'elle a cherchés
finalement dans cette campagne nicolas
sarkozy rend les coups le président n'a
pas pu rendre tous les coups parce que
le président il est naturellement dans
l'exercice de sa fonction au dessus du
débat très souvent et même si nicolas
sarkozy sait rendre les coups il n'a pas
abusé de cela maintenant qu'elle est
candidat comme disent les anglais c'est
it forte at tu me cherches tu me trouves
la cgt la chercher elle la trouve
c'est très fort se déplacer je viens de
vos liens mais j'ai reçu comme premier
ministre avec la cgt l'un sur il
assurait que le président de la russie
se renouent avec les syndicats je leur
ai inversement
mais sans doute qu'il faudra réfléchir
sur l'indépendance syndicale et je pense
que ce débat n'est pas inutile
moi j'ai trouvé que monsieur chérèque
était un leader syndical indépendant
qu'il avait une crédibilité personnelle
il avait fait des choix courageux je le
respecte pour ça mais il est clair que
de temps en temps il ya certaines
sections syndicales syndicats qui se
comporte de manière extrêmement politisé
et donc on a vu que la cfdt quelquefois
avait des c des sections qui ont sur le
plan électoral abusés par des
manifestations qui étaient
d'humanisation typiquement électorale
d'ailleurs je note que la cfdt a su
faire la police pour sanctionner
quelquefois des sections qui ne se
comportait pas de manière suffisamment
indépendante des réseaux politiques donc
moi j'ai une estime forte pour la cfdt
je manque de la cfdt a une vraie culture
d'indépendance qui n'est pas le cas de
la cgt et je pense que nicolas sarkozy a
montré spécifiquement que si les
syndicats ne voulaient pas qu'on leur
reproche leur politisation il fallait
qu'ils raisonnent en dehors du débat
politique mais à vouloir jouer avec le
feu on se brûle les doigts parlons de
l'islam radical quelques semaines après
les affreuses tuerie de montauban et
puis de toulouse on s'aperçoit que donc
des décisions sont prises pour expulser
du territoire des extrémistes notamment
des imams est ce la preuve que l'on a
sous-estimé le fondamentalisme radical
dans notre pays jean pierre raffarin ou
bien alors est ce comme on l'entend à
gauche joue également du côté du
syndicat de la magistrature une
manipulation en pleine campagne
je ne crois pas qu'il s'agit de
manipulation mais je pense que il y à
vraiment sur ces sujets une profonde
inquiétude dans le pays et que c'est la
responsabilité de l'état de bien montrer
que nous sommes extrêmement vigilants et
qu'au fond quand on avait dit qu'on
souhaitait que les iman puisse parler
français puissent être dans la logique
républicaine
je trouve qu'il est bon de le rappeler
de temps en temps et donc l'inquiétude
elle est dans le peuple aujourd'hui il
faut
assurer le pignon public sur le fait que
l'état veille à l'exercice et
républicain de la laïcité
vous êtes un point clé que je pense que
ce point de vue là il est bon de montrer
que l'état reste mobilisé
particulièrement en campagne électorale
pendant toutes circonstances il faut
dire que les événements quand même été
d'une violence extrême avec des
atrocités qui ont te mords tri
l'ensemble du pays
la cicatrice n'est pas éteinte et je
pense que pour notamment la mémoire des
victimes devons assurer à la fois un
devoir de mémoire un devoir de vigilance
est donc je pense que ceci et doit être
l'expression d'une certaine fermeté de
l'état me va de soi que je ne souhaite
pas polémiquer sur ce sujet parce que la
quantité a été tel que la bonne réponse
a été celle de l'unité nationale je
pense que la seule façon qu'on a de
répondre aux terroristes c'est
d'affirmer l'unité puisqu'au fond c'est
qu'il dit à plusieurs reprises
l'objectif du terrorisme et de
déstabiliser la société pas en la
divisant donc quand elles se rassemblent
elle montre sa force en toc vice
président du sénat est ce que vous
pouvez approuvé la décision du
gouvernement de ne pas laisser
auditionné les responsables du centre du
renseignement par une commission ad-hoc
et si nous l'avons approuvé ce matin en
bureau politique ici au sénat avec jean
claude gaudin une atteinte à la fonction
de contrôle du scénario il est clair que
là il ya une instrumentalisation du rôle
du sénat qu'en période électorale que
nous n'apprécions pas et donc nous
pensons qu'il vaut mieux avoir une
certaine réserve sur ces sujets que ce
qui est fait là est une agitation qui
est ambigu sur le plan politique dans la
moindre des hypothèses est donc dans ce
cas là je pense que avoir une attitude
de réserve est plutôt à l'honneur de
l'ump l'affairé bettencourt ont dit
qu'elles se rapprochent certains
l'espère de nicolas sarkozy qui parle
aujourd'hui d'une boule puante est ce
que vous auriez pu comme françois fillon
qui a retiré ses propos premier ministre
en exercice critiqué la mise en
détention du principal témoin l'ancien
gestionnaire de fortune de madame
bettencourt monsieur de maistre
non je pense que il respecte le travail
de la justice bon il est clair que dans
un certain nombre de circonstances on a
vu que cette logique de la ve n'était
pas toujours la meilleure logique d'une
justice qui se veut libre et
indépendante et donc je pense que les
pressions sur l'aveu sont pas forcément
des bons mais ça je ne sais pas si c'est
ce qui se passe dans l'affairé
bettencourt il ya des des vraisemblances
qui sont préoccupantes de ce point de
vue là et je trouve que c'est pas une
bonne façon de mettre quelqu'un donc
dans cette situation pour en espérant
qu'il puisse avouer quelque chose donc
je ne sais pas si c'est ça qui a été dit
la stratégie de la justice mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'elles démentent que ce
soit sa stratégie est donc de ce point
de vue là je trouve que il faut faire
confiance à la justice que nicolas
sarkozy est très sûr de ses comptes
puisque les a présentés de manière tout
à fait professionnel et très détaillé
qui l'ont été accepté comme tel donc il
n'a rien à craindre pour cela quant à
dire qu'il a rencontré monsieur andré
bettencourt qui était un parlementaire
un ancien ministre
ami de monsieur mitterrand par ailleurs
qui jouent un rôle dans notre vie
politique nationale et rien
d'exceptionnel avoir rencontré andré
bettencourt donc je pense que dans cette
affaire il y a sans doute beaucoup de
malice je trouve que je ne sais pas de
qui mais il ya de la manipulation est ce
que je note c'est que y'a une grosse
affaire à marseille et une grosse
affaire à lille etc on parle beaucoup de
celle là plus que d autres donc on
raisonne le parti de danse je vois qu'en
terme en terme de deux temps de parole
je vois qu'on entre les candidats on
veut une égalité stricte dans les
affaires on emporte tout à fait cette
égalité je trouve dans l'immédiat
médiatiquement médiatiquement il ya des
gens
qui sont poursuivis aujourd'hui même par
exemple mediapart qui dit la même chose
d'ailleurs que ségolène royal nicolas
sarkozy avec sa réélection cherche à
conserver son immunité présidentielle
pour ne pas à répondre devant les juges
qu'est ce que vous dites que cela madame
royal est à l'égal d'elle-même et que sa
crédibilité dans ce débat national est
mince alors on va accueillir frédéric
dumoulin agence france presse dans un
instant vous aviez annoncé jean pierre
raffarin qu'une seconde campagne
présidentielle n'est jamais magique
est-ce que celle que mène actuellement
nicolas sarkozy diffère de la précédente
c'est ce qu'on voit avec jérôme rabier
pas un seul président ne s'est dérobée
mais tenter une deuxième conquête de
l'elysée s'avère souvent compliqué la
défaite de valéry giscard d'estaing en
80 rappelle que la magie suscité que
c'est un une fois le premier mandat
achevé un défi auquel nicolas sarkozy
est aujourd'hui confronté avec un
avantage pour son équipe une crise
économique qui n'incite pas à rêver pour
une fois peut-être le fait d'être le
sortant ça protège ça rassure protéger
rassurer mais surtout reconquérir après
cinq ans passés à gouverner cinq ans de
popularité qui flirte avec deux records
de morosité c'est précis qu'une baguette
magique qu'il faut pour effacer ce passé
alors le président lâche on élixir
miracle une proposition par jour
le programme n'est pourtant pas encore
sorti du chapeau à l'ump on préfère la
réactivité
quitte à parfois manier un double
discours à la fois le discours du
protecteur rassembleur du pays est à la
fois il se met du côté du peuple contre
et s'est dit pour justifier le fait que
lui comprend le peuple sur des
thématiques finalement très très
droitière en 2007 ils criaient j'ai
changé et prôné la rupture en 2012
l'homme a mûri et proclame j'ai appris
il se voit pourtant encore comme
antisystème après cinq ans à l'elysée et
joue les prestidigitateurs
contre les sondages contre la presse
contre les élites il rêve de faire
apparaître d'invisibles reports de voix
au second tour et promet de faire mentir
ceux qui prédisent sa défaite au soir du
6 mai ce qui est très intéressant dans
cette deuxième campagne c'est qu'il a
toujours aussi faim ce qui n'est pas la
stratégie habituelle des sortants en
réalité hollande se comportent en
sortant c'est une campagne à l'envers et
nicolas sarkozy en challenger si une
deuxième campagne est rarement magique
nicolas sarkozy ne compte pas pour
autant à mener sans panache ils
inversent les rôles mène une guerre de
mouvement se positionne en conquérant
quitte à parfois tenté de recréer cinq
ans après la même potion magique que
celle qui l'a portée au sommet voilà
donc en fait on nous dit dans le camp
présidentiel que la à partir du 22 avril
il s'agira donc de changer de braquet
parce que mais comment on passe d'une
d'un second tour où on essaye de
récupérer les voix centristes
comment on passe de à ça alors quand on
a eu un premier tour quand même qui est
assez droitier dans la campagne nicolas
sarkozy comment on peut faire les deux
alors donc l'hypothèse positive dans le
camp sarkozy c'est d'avoir une dynamique
de premier non c'est à dire d'avoir une
avance au premier tour qui crée dans
l'opinion
un sentiment qui est plutôt un sentiment
favorable à la culture de nicolas
sarkozy et vous le reportage le montrer
bien personne ne croyait les huit ans de
sarkozy l'anti sarkozysme dans le square
du premier tour il y a une dynamique qui
se crée je me souviens par exemple soir
du premier tour des européennes alors en
fait du seul tour des européennes avec
un tour ben la gauche au total faisait
mieux que nous mais comme on était en
tête il ya eu un vent d'espoir très
important quête qui s'est développée
dans le pays donc je pense que celui qui
sera en tête aura une dynamique à ce
moment là le débat se fera sur les
propositions et donc je pense que au
deuxième tour nicolas sarkozy devra
avancer un certain nombre de
propositions et ces propositions devront
être rassembleuse pour le pays donc je
pense que tout le problème d'une
campagne comme celle de nicolas sarkozy
et de rester avec des réserves
d'accélération de nous qui est arrivé le
soir du premier tour complètement
essoufflé
ce qui est assez surprenant c'est ce qui
est arrivé à monsieur hollande qui a eu
une dynamique pendant les primaires et
s'est trompé de ligne d'arrivée il a
franchi la ligne d'arrivée des primaires
et là il a repris sa respiration et
finalement ils ne retrouvent pas sans
second tour mais il a envoyé donc assez
nicolas sarkozy a envoyé à ses deux
signaux envers l'électorat d'extrême
droite pour pouvoir se concentrer au
second tour dans l'électorat centriste
monsieur bayrou mais vous savez qu'ils
refusent cette analyse là une partie du
peuple par le parti de droite et de
centre dans lequel ils refusent cette
idée que les gens qu'ils voteraient tous
tous pour marine le pen sont des gens
d'extrême droite mais ce sont des gens
qui expriment un vote protestataire
et donc c'est pour ça que vos fonds il a
une fait une performance et le reportage
de disais tout à l'heure qui me paraît
assez clair c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing en 80 n'a pas réussi à quitter
ses habits de président et à prendre un
costume de candidat il est resté
président d'une certaine manière puisque
vous les atouts charme et finalement il
n'est jamais vraiment entré en campagne
comme candidat nicolas sarkozy est entré
en campagne comme candidat est tout le
problème pour lui est de ne pas arriver
essoufflé à la fin du premier tour
d'avoir encore quelques propositions
pour le second tour et avoir une accusée
de rigueur et vous pensez qu'il va
réussir le pari de faire oublier le
président impopulaire qu'il a pu être
écouté
très franchement il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne pensaient pas qu'il serait
capable de le faire à ce stade de la
campagne et donc moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui qu'il est capable tout à
fait de changer cette donne
on avait pensé que cette élection
présidentielle c'est un référendum pour
ou contre sarkozy et je vois bien dans
le pays aujourd'hui monter le comparatif
quel est celui qui a le meilleur projet
le meilleur programme quel est celui qui
a le plus de caractère
quel est celui capable de mieux le
président et la france quel est celui
qui l'aura internationale la plus forte
et finalement je pense qu'on va rentrer
dans un un comparatif et le soir du
premier tour
on va comparer la réaction de monsieur
hollande l'arrêt axe
de monsieur sarkozy et pendant les
quinze jours on va comparer leurs
propositions et dans ce mano a mano
je pense que l'énergie et la puissance
sera probablement dans le camp sarkozy
dans qu'elle ne m'aime les propositions
sont-elles en préparation vous le savez
là vous les avez esquissé medici tv
tours espère bien confirmer jean pierre
raffarin alors je confirme que c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous avons quelques
réflexions
mais vous me permettrait de garder cela
pour moi parce que par définition la
ligne stratégique de notre candidat est
de tout faire pour être en tête au
premier tour pour créer la dynamique et
ensuite accéléré va sûrement dans quels
domaines régaliens sur les questions
économiques
c'est bien d'essayer une deuxième fois
mais je ne peux pas je ne peux pas vous
répondre je serai pas loyal mon candidat
si je dévoilais avant le premier tour ce
n'était pas là en bétique le second tour
mais c'est quand même aussi des chiffres
donc au niveau de lecture à monsieur
bayrou est ce que vous invitez le
premier vous à envisager monsieur bayrou
à matignon est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un bon moyen est ce que est ce que
vous pensez que monsieur baou va rallier
nicolas sarkozy vous pensez que c'est
c'est bien avant c'est ça ou je n'en
sais strictement rien au moment je ne
peux pas je pense que françois bayrou a
d'abord en tête d'essayer de faire le
meilleur score possible pour le premier
tour donc pour le moment lui aussi il
est comme nicolas sarkozy il est en-deça
de 2007 mais un candidat espère toujours
en campagne donc nicolas sarkozy est à
fond dans sa campagne françois bayrou
est aussi à fond dans sa campagne espère
redresser pendant les quelques jours qui
sont devant nous redresser la situation
je pense que on a avec françois hollande
devrait proximité son idée de référendum
par exemple qu'il veut faire
le soir des élections législatives c'est
quelque chose que je trouve du point de
vue du programme de l'ump de notre
honneur tout à fait acceptable ces
deux-là cumul des mandats c'est une dose
de proportionnelle c'est un certain
nombre de sujets de moralisation de la
vie politique qui sont tout à fait
acceptables cette idée du référendum le
présent
candidat pourrait la reprendre
officiellement je ne sais pas ce qu'est
ce qui pourra se passer mais disons que
s'il fallait passer par un accord de
cette nature il y à un grand nombre de
sujets sur lequel il peut y avoir
compatibilité moi j'étais dans le même
gouvernement que françois bayrou de 95 à
97 je lui ai succédé comme secrétaire
général de l'udf je sais bien qu'on a
beaucoup de choses en commun et que si
on veut travailler ensemble sur un
certain nombre de sujets on doit pouvoir
définir une perspective commune
ça demandera naturellement que lui même
soit satisfait de sa campagne que lui
même était été respectées comme il doit
être respecté et que lui-même fait ses
propres choix ou comment on passe d'un
françois bayrou qui en 2007 disait je ne
voterai pas pour nicolas sarkozy et qui
a passé cinq ans à critiquer le
gouvernement au moins autant que
l'opposition comment on peut passer à
une alliance entre les deux mains à côté
je pense que monsieur mélenchon
travaille tous les jours à cette
hypothèse est que plus monsieur
mélenchon tire la campagne à gauche plus
du tiers du centre se trouve libéré et
il est clair que monsieur mélenchon
aujourd'hui est un problème qui est posé
à la gauche en la radicalisation
l'arrêté licence sur sa gauche et donc
au fond au centre il reste aujourd'hui
un espace auquel monsieur bayrou veut
s'adresser et qui est un espace de mon
point de vue disponible pour le second
tour par rapport à ses électeurs
monsieur gros monsieur bayrou ça peut
être un monsieur mélenchon peut être un
élément en fait de justification à je
pense que l'appel à la révolution à la
surrection citoyenne toute cette vision
emballé de la vie politique c'est pas
tellement la tempérance humanis sentry
ce n'est pas les forces de l'équilibré
donc je pense que de ce point de vue là
monsieur mélenchon décale à gauche
la campagne de monsieur hollande et où
quelqu'un ça libère le centre pour des
initiatives d'ouverture de la droite et
de françois bayrou à matignon ce que
prévu blue a écouté il en a les
capacités
s'il ya un accord politique si la
victoire peut dépendre de lui s'il y a
des possibilités d'accord et d'entendre
politique
et programmatique pas à exclure et je ne
vois pas pourquoi ce serait à priori à
exclure quand on cherche à rassembler le
pays quand on cherche à rassembler il
faut bien envisager des rassemblements
donc est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un accord
programmatique oui est ce que monsieur
bayrou a les capacités à exercer cette
responsabilité est ce qu'on aura les
circonstances qu'ils permettront je n'en
sais rien mais en tout cas il n'y a pas
deux postulats préalable qui ferait de
matignon n'a pas déjà été premier doute
renoncer parce que c'est ce qui se dit
pourtant on met ça vous savez j'étais
ceux qui croient les plusieurs profils 1
qui sont évoqués logis paix quand même
pourquoi pas votre cas ça dépendra
beaucoup de ce que seront les priorités
du président de la république on peut
imaginer que le président de la
république s'oriente vers un scénario
très européen puisque on voit que
l'europe manque d'un vrai leadership
aujourd'hui donc on peut imaginer que le
président fasse de leadership européens
une priorité de son mandat ou quelqu'un
il a besoin de quelqu'un de grande
expérience à matignon ou autrement il
peut renouveler la formule qu'il a
développée en étant vraiment en charge
des questions intérieures et de ce point
de vue là il peut prendre la nouvelle
génération et faire confiance à la
nouvelle génération jean françois copé
ou un autre donc il peut y avoir des
circonstances que le président seul
pourra décider mais je pense que nous
aurons besoin de nicolas sarkozy pour
assurer un leadership européen pour
l'instant de monsieur copé est ce qu'on
peut cumuler la tête de l'ump et
matignon
est-ce qu'on peut encore le faire ça ce
sont aux protagonistes de la décidée il
ya aucune aucune
circonstances qui peuvent nous dire que
c'est pas possible puisque de fait le
premier ministre et le chef de la
majorité
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est
juridiquement impossible donc est ce que
le président sera d'accord est ce que le
premier ministre et mentale serait
d'accord ça c'est halde
il faut poser la question justement quel
que soit le scénario la présidentielle
pour l'ump
on sait que vous accueillez monsieur
copé non sur vos terres poitevines en
deux jours dernière faire si une
campagne un peu je sais pas tout de
suite quand tu es je vais proposer non
mais c'est pour pour la campagne des
présidentielles mais va venir deux jours
une super meeting comme ça entre 17 et
19 heures c'était bien deux jours après
le meeting on va dîner dans une ferme
avant de rencontrer les médecins l'ont
nova temps verra les boulangers la
première heure le temps je je n'attends
pas que la campagne dans cette démarche
de densité et à prendre le temps de
l'affectif et donc quelles que soient
nos outils de la présidentielle est ce
que vous pensez puis c'est votre ami est
ce que vous pensez que il est l'homme
idoine pour le poste de dirigeant l'ump
est-ce qu'il doit garder l'ump selon
vous je pense qu'il est temps
circonstances puisque il était en charge
de ce parti pendant une période qui
n'est pas facile pour lui et donc il a
je pense bien mené et son travail donc
tout dépendra l'étalement du scénario
mais enfin il n'a vraiment pas démérité
je trouve que à la fois dans les
questions d'organisation le parti
vraiment en état de marche et dans ses
capacités personnelles notamment quand
il a été opposé dans un débat à la
télévision à françois hollande il a
montré un vrai potentiel personnel donc
quelqu'un qui est à la fois organisée et
qui a un fort potentiel et tu es en plus
les temps en place je pense qu'il peut
faire l'unité
donc s'il ya un match entre
jean françois copé et françois fillon
pour la tête de l'ump pour vous le choix
est clair
écoutez nous verrons ça le moment venu
moi je ne veux pas diviser ma famille
j'étais un des fondateurs de l'ump
je souhaite le rassemblement de l'ump
nous avons aujourd'hui un secrétaire
général à la fois qui est jeune et qui
n'a pas démérité donc et qui a tout un
fort potentiel
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas faire l'unité autour de lui
s'il devait y avoir d'autres scénarios
nous les examinerons quand ils se
poseront bon l'avenir de françois fillon
vous le voyez comment quand on quitte
matignon
écoutez françois fillon est quelqu'un de
serein il est plutôt satisfait du
travail qu'il a accompli
il est apaisé donc je pense qu'il aura
besoin de se ressourcer un peu d'aller
chercher des horizons un peu nouveau
mais il reviendra au palais sant
campagne pas d'ici là il sera en
campagne pour les élections législatives
et ensuite je pense qu'il ira un peu se
ressourcer mais c'est quelqu'un qu'on
retrouvera sur la scène politique
évidemment on va bien pas bien vous vous
engagez pas non je me parle non mais
vous savez je suis dans une campagne
électorale doit de gagner oui non je ne
veux pas diviser forget évidemment mes
préférences j'ai compris je vois que
vous avez un livre où j'ai écrit noir
sur blanc assez mais la 6éme ans que je
pensais d un oui je marcherai toujours
celle d'un livre qui est très très libre
donc mais en campagne électorale vous
l'êtes - ou du moins il est clair il est
clair que je ne veux pas que mes propos
servent l'adversaire c'est une
définition historique importante quelle
est la différence entre la diversité et
la division c'est quand l'adversaire se
servent de l'argument vous de la
diversité c'est dire cet outil là notre
temps la division c'est utile au camp de
l'adversaire donc je ne veux pas qu'il y
est mais pour des propos qui émane de
moi qui puisse servir à mettre d'accord
sur les hommes est également sur le
programme de nicolas sarkozy 1 depuis le
début de cette émission on l'a vu merci
frédéric père inferno va nous rejoindre
donc mais d'abord ce rappel du rôle que
vous
données ou que vous vous donnez jean
pierre raffarin auprès de nicolas
sarkozy jusqu'à cette entrée en campagne
puisque vous n'aviez pas l'image d'un
béni oui oui aujourd'hui vous faites
plus attention à vos propos vous l'avez
explicite et on l'a compris c'est ce
qu'on voit avec tam tran huy jean pierre
raffarin c'est le poil à gratter de la
majorité depuis le début du quinquennat
l'ancien premier ministre critique
parfois ouvertement la politique de
nicolas sarkozy
quitte à agacer à l'ump je voudrais pas
que jean pierre raffarin devienne la
tatie danielle de l'ump avec toutes les
semaines un nouveau sujet de fâcherie
tva sur les parcs à thème mais surtout
taxe professionnelle sur ce dernier
point tati jean pierre est allé jusqu'à
diriger la fronde de la haute assemblée
23 sénateurs de la majorité pas d'accord
pour sacrifier les collectivités
territoriales comme jean pierre raffarin
n'est pas quelqu'un qui a sa langue dans
sa poche
eh bien il a utilisé j'allais dire son
aura médiatique et il a entraîné
derrière lui un certain nombre d'élus
qui trouvait également que ce projet
n'était pas bon voilà après le dialogue
s'est ouvert évidemment poil à gratter
ça a dérangé certains qui auraient bien
voulu nous faire avaler quelque part la
pilule jusque dans ses mémoires l'ancien
premier ministre épingle les excès de
nicolas sarkozy ces remontées de
gaullisme autoritaire ces appels à la
rupture qu'il compare à des moulinets et
son omnipotence de présidents premiers
ministres et oui c'est le risque que
l'on encourt à créer une union à partir
de tendance parfois disparates entre la
droite populaire la droite sociale les
centriste les gaullistes ou encore les
libéraux on peine parfois à accorder ses
violons sauf aujourd'hui en pleine
campagne
la majorité se veut plus soudés que
jamais à donner un parti politique c'est
pas un régiment de légion étrangère il
ya des gens qui ont le droit d'avoir des
opinions différentes
par contre ce qui compte c'est qu'ils
soient d'accord sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est justement les le socle
de valeurs que défend nicolas dans
sarkozy dans cette campagne
enfin encore quelques semaines de trêve
et les querelles pourront reprendre
voilà jean pierre raffarin donc vous ne
voulez pas critiquer ni divisés mais
vous écris sont là en fut le sujet est
le sujet est un peu polémique je te sur
le fond très franchement entre hollande
et sarkozy je n'ai jamais hésité une
seconde et une élection ce sera pour qui
vous votez quand je moi j'arrive de
chine
quand je pense que monsieur hollande n'a
jamais mis les pieds en charge quand je
pense qu'il ya du toit bien sûr que
c'est rédhibitoire si vous voyez le
monde change et si vous voyez les jeunes
français qui vont là bas parce qu'ils
sont quelquefois sans espoir ici qu'ils
craignent d'avoir des difficultés
si vous ne vous rendez pas compte
aujourd'hui que le brésil la russie la
chine l'inde l'afrique du sud ce qu'on
appelle les bric ce qu'on fait un sommet
pour la deuxième année consécutive où il
trace un peu des perspectives pour le
monde si on n'est pas branché sur ce
monde là il est clair qu'on passe à côté
de ce qu'est vraiment l'histoire du pays
de ce point de vue là l'aura
internationale le leadership de nicolas
sarkozy est sans conteste hyperpuissant
à côté de françois hollande qui ne
semble avoir dans sa carrière politique
consacrée la plupart de son temps à
distribuer les investitures du parti
socialiste bon dernier argument choc de
l'ump françois hollande n'a jamais été
en chine
on avait entendu ça ce week-end dans la
bouche alain juppé mais franchement vous
trouvez pas ça normal il faudrait que la
france ouvre les fenêtres quand vous
regardez le monde aujourd'hui les
problèmes des français l'emploi
c'est la question des délocalisations
les flux migratoires la sécurité donc et
aussi évidemment le pouvoir d'achat avec
les questions monétaires
vous voyez bien que l'international est
entré dans notre vie et au fond
qu'est-ce que une expérience à la tête
d'un parti politique comme françois
hollande qui n'a jamais assisté un
conseil européen qui n'a jamais été à
une organisation de l'onu qui n'a jamais
été dans des grands pays aujourd'hui
avec lesquels nous avons ne peut pas
faire violence
sortant jean pierre raffarin mais non
mais je connais des gens qui ont une
expérience internationale à gauche
je connais des gens qui ont une
expérience et un sauna gaulle ségolène
royal qui est allé en chine
c'était la brave à 6,7 c'était un
excellent bravitude
je leur paie rumeur nicolas sarkozy nous
disait la une de paris match était la
semaine dernière vous l'avez peut-être
pas vu je serai un président différent
dans quel sens où vous l'entendez
ben je pense que il sera peut-être plus
ouvert à une nouvelle pratique
institutionnelle c'est à dire un
président qui qui serait moins
gouvernants un président qui préside
tous ceux qui gouvernent - qui laisse
davantage le premier ministre gouverner
se dire pour moi je les skis c'est dans
le débat tout à l'heure je pense que
avec angela merkel
nous sommes dans une situation
européenne assez fragile très
franchement quand je vois justement la
croissance des grands pôles mondiaux
je pense que c'est le moment où les
pôles sont émergents que nous l'europe
nous affichons nos difficultés
je pense que nous sommes très fragiles
sur le plan international pour
l'européen et qu'il faut de créer un
leadership pour défendre et mobiliser
l'europe parlait aux opinions publiques
européennes qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
leader c'est quelqu'un qui parle aux
opinions publiques
monsieur von roll paul que quelqu'un
tout à fait estimable on ne parle ne
parle pas aux opinions publiques même la
ville classe nicolas sarkozy madame
merkel parle aux opinions publiques je
pense que nicolas sarkozy pourrait être
avec un gala merkel ce leader dont
l'europe a besoin au quelqu'un ça
devrait le conduire à s'appuyer sur un
premier ministre qui gouvernerait
davantage donc moindre et lance sur la
scène nationale plus sur la scène
internationale et on rationne européenne
et européennes
exactement un président différent c'est
aussi un président - au tt ou disons que
le caractère est une qualité mais il
faut il faut pouvoir aussi être attentif
aux autres et je pense que nicolas
sarkozy dans cette campagne est fait des
efforts sur l'humain mais il est très
ouvert ce matin on était en réunion du
comité stratégique il fait un tour de
table avant de lui-même de sesca
l'exemple et d'accepter ça voulait
donner mais je peux vous le dire je
témoigne
il demande aux uns et aux autres notre
analyse
is et il n'intervient qu'en fin de
réunion et donc c'était pas comme ça
dans le passé dans les pieds déjeuner de
la majorité et donc je trouve que le
candidat nicolas sarkozy a ouvert un peu
docteur du président donc c'est laisser
plus de place à l'ecoute et aussi au
doute
je pense qu'il faut pas rêver avec
nicolas sarkozy c'est quelqu'un de
décidé
c'est quelqu'un de décidé c'est
quelqu'un d'engagé mais je pense que à
la tête de l'état il faut pas installer
le doute permanent et laufon la fermeté
de son caractère est plutôt un atout
surtout en période de crise dans vos
mémoires vous regretté que nicolas
sarkozy ait laissé s'égarer plusieurs
brebis de l'ump je pense à jean louis
borloo je pense à rama yade rachida dati
aussi à une certaine période
il semble aujourd'hui que tout le monde
sans revenu autour de la table je crois
que jean louis borloo et était présent
ce matin la réunion stratégique autant
du candidat sarkozy je ne me trompe pas
on se tait raison voilà
rama yade elle dit je ne suis pas rallié
mes alliés c'est quoi la nuance
ça veut dire que l exprime sa liberté de
choix n'allait pas dans une situation
qui lui est imposé elle est dans une
situation qu'elle a choisi moi je vais
vous dire que nicolas sarkozy a fait un
énorme travail relationnel pour en effet
faire en sorte que la droite dans cette
élection soit rassemblée souvent comparé
la situation d'aujourd'hui avec celle de
giscard en 80 mais en 80 il y a non
seulement le projet ancien premier
ministre jacques chirac qui est présent
et qui fait une campagne assez fort
qu'avec une thématique globale assez de
divisions de marie france garaud dans la
campagne la droite en 80 est très
divisée vous que la sarkozie a réussi à
rassembler alors naturellement il est la
tentative morin attend petits lutins
l'attend villepin il ya eu un certain
nombre de tentatives
mais aujourd'hui regardons les faits les
faits la droite et le centre sont
rassemblés et jacques chirac qui s'en va
un peu partout en ce moment en répétant
qu'il votera pour hollande est ce que ça
c'est une blague de vieux monsieur je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas entendu dire ça il
l'a dit encore récemment un des
personnes là peut-être mais je n'ai pas
entendu dire ça donc
je sais qu'il l'avait dit une première
fois dans un project dans un contexte
qu'il y avait légitimé un communiqué de
démenti donc je ne sais pas quelle est
la réalité de cela je sais que
évidemment mais jacques chirac pour les
carhaisiens une certaine estime de toute
façon mais il l'a redit ce week end
jacques chirac personne n'a jamais dit
autant de mal de moi que nicolas sarkozy
on a l'impression que c'est un vieux
l'ont eu un vieux lion qui finalement
n'a pas pansé ses plaies
je n'ai pas ce sentiment là je les ai
vus n'ya pas longtemps le président
m'est apparu comme étant lui-même assez
apaisés donc je ne crois pas qu'il soit
dans cette logique de pensée par rapport
à lui-même
donc cette phrase là oui elle me
surprendre sa part c'est pas et le vote
pour nicolas sarkozy n'est pas fonction
de l'attitude des gars sargis vis-à-vis
de lui donc où il estime qu'il est le
meilleur pour diriger le pays ou pas
mais je pense que cela lui de le dire
mais je me méfie de ces propos qui sont
rapportés
bernadette chirac elle a assuré que
françois hollande n'avait pas le gabarit
d'un d'un président ça vous a surpris
elle a corrigé passer le mot était quand
même assez bien trouver les raisons de
dire qu'il était fort mais le gabarit
mais je pense que c'est
c'est aussi votre avis c'est un peu en
tout cas sur plan international oui je
crois que bon ça hollande quelqu'un et
quelqu'un d'estimables est quelqu'un qui
a une expérience politique je dirais
même politicienne de chef de parti
donc c'est quelqu'un d'estimables mais
c'est vrai que en termes de leadership
international
il est assez des buts en trois semaines
avant le premier tour jean-pierre
raffarin l'abstention reste très forte
dans les intentions de vote aux
alentours de 30%
est ce que pour vous ça signifie un réel
désintérêt vis-à-vis de cette élection
présidentielle là je ne crois pas parce
que quand je vois les meetings quand je
vois les animations de campagne sur le
terrain il ya beaucoup plus de
mobilisation pendant la fille en 2007
donc semble-t-il la participation je ne
suis je ne sais pas ce que je pense
l'important c'est que ceux qui
pourraient être mécontents et qui
auraient envie de voter ne doivent pas
trouver la campagne de monsieur hollande
très mobilisatrice donc
j'ai le sentiment en tout cas pour ce
qui est notre camp que notre camp et
bien mobilisés je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
face est soit très mobilisés en tout cas
la dynamique mélenchon nous laisse
penser qu'il y à gauche des gens qui
trouvent la campagne de monsieur
hollande insuffisante mais il y aura un
deuxième tour est pour l'instant lié à
semble-t-il peu de réserves de voix pour
nicolas sarkozy il a vraiment vous
disiez une chance sur deux au début de
l'émission savait avant de rentrer en
campagne
les prévisions de second tour c'était 62
on est passé à 60 40 on est passé
progressivement et je vois maintenant
des 53 47 en étant je vois les tendances
et aujourd'hui on est à 63 40 à 53 47
moi je pense qu'on finira le premier
tour à moins de 52 48
parce que si on est là à 53,47
aujourd'hui on sera à moins de 52 48 ça
veut dire que tout va se jouer dans les
quinze jours dans ce qu'attendent les
français qu'est ce qu'ils attendent des
français aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir
si monsieur finale des idées sur
l'emploi ce qu'ils attendent c'est le
match hollande sarkozy sarkozy hollande
qui est le mieux capables pour diriger
le pays en période de crise ce match là
ce mano a mano
il démarre le soir du premier tour et ce
mano a mano à mano ils l'empêchent
justement ces deux candidats de
participer à des débats comme le demande
françois bayrou avec tout l'ensemble des
candidats au premier tour de la
présidentielle vous je vais fonder cette
demande effectivement d'un
débat à 10 je pense que le débat a dit
c'est tout à fait faisable mais on peut
pas demander à tous les candidats
d'accepter la loi de quelqu'un dont ils
peuvent se faire représenter que se
fasse représenter s'ils veulent se faire
représenter
mais je pense qu'on ne va pas obliger
quiconque de participer à un débat la
campagne électorale c'est quand même la
liberté des candidats de s'exprimer de
dire ce qu'ils ont à dire donc un
candidat qui voudraient imposer un débat
à tel ou tel
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît
usurpée alors que qu'il y ait un débat
avec tous les candidats et où leurs
représentants
ça me paraît être une pratique
démocratique vous avez à nouveau tendu
la main on l'a vue d'une façon assez
spectaculaire tout à l'heure à françois
bayrou un jean pierre raffarin il
dénonce aujourd'hui cette absence de
débat a dit c'est dit il y à une entente
clandestine entre françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy vous pensez que c'est la
parole d'un candidat qui voit ses forces
il disparaître
non mais je comprenais bien que de toute
façon pour nicolas sarkozy je vois pas
pourquoi
très franchement il errait dans un débat
où il aurait eu neuf adversaires contre
lui il faut quand même bien avoir
compris que du classique
sauf que celui qui est sortant il a tout
le monde contre lui c'est pas tout à
fait pareil et qui aura des solidarités
avec moi il y aurait des 6 d'alerté avec
les uns ou avec les autres donc ce qu'il
faut bien nommer un plan démontre
mélenchon est violent ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
nicolas sarkozy a envie de gagner et
qu'il ne fera les choses qu'en fonction
de son objectif qui est la victoire pour
le pays et donc il décidera sa
participation sa non participation en
fonction de la probabilité qu'il estime
de pouvoir gagner en fonction de telle
ou telle attitude
il veut gagner il ne veut pas
aujourd'hui se sacrifier on a voulu
d'une certaine manière
l'exposé terriblement dans cette
campagne il veut gagner et donc qu'il va
prendre des attitudes nécessaires palais
la dernière question avec un peu de
recul comment vous vous sentez dans le
sénat de gauche jean pierre raffarin
peut coûter jusqu'à maintenant ça allait
plutôt bien ça continue et puis je mais
je trouve que bon c'est histoire un peu
de de commission denquête avec cette
commission d'évaluation des lois qui
veut se prendre un peu pour un saint
juste du sénat s'est pas tout à fait
notre amie
sion sénatoriales donc je pense que il
ya quelques petits réglages qui sont
encore nécessaires mais globalement il
n'y a pas de difficultés insurmontables
et quand la gauche aura compris que si
elle veut notre concours à ne peut
l'avoir que quand elle respecte les
principes républicains
nous sommes tout à fait capables d'avoir
une bonne entente au sénat donc je pense
qu'il ya quelques réglages et que
monsieur assouline a encore de pratique
militante qu'il va falloir quelque peu
apaisé par rapport aux pratiques
sénatoriales traditionnel ici on prend
de l'altitude s'il souhaite que vous
collaboriez avec lucien c'est le souhait
torse et voilà vous tout seul quelques
jours tout ça merci jean pierre raffarin
merci bonsoir à tous